let's go next to quentin from portland
is that portland maine or portland
oregon
quinton from portland yes i can
oh uh portland oregon beautiful
um so i had a conversation with my
mother who was extremely extremely
right-wing okay and uh she was blaming
uh the lefties or the dems or the libs
you know whatever she wants to say uh
about leaking
the supreme court document
and
i didn't really have a rebuttal saying
that like i've heard you say that it's
more likely uh a right-leaning person
leaked it
but i i i couldn't really clearly tell
her why i i have that opinion so if you
could just clear that up i would really
appreciate it and then also okay let's
take it piece by piece then i'll get to
your second question so to be clear what
i've said before is in terms of just
plausibility it's equally plausible that
a left winger or a right winger leaked
the supreme court decision you could say
well it's a left winger who wanted to
try to create outrage to have pressure
on the judges to change their votes and
end up uh maintaining roe v wade or you
could say it's a right winger
who decided to leak it out of fear that
some of the justices planning to
overturn roe v wade might change their
minds to put pressure on them to
maintain the positions they had in the
february draft so plausibility is kind
of equal but we have some reporting from
long-time supreme court reporters
including from npr
who say that the the overarching belief
within the court right now is that the
leaker was a right winger but ultimately
we don't know so what i would ask is
what evidence do you have to support
that the leaker was left-wing i would go
with that and of course there is no such
evidence
yeah on a number of issues that's kind
of my response and
yeah um and then also um please just
google josh dallas on your show you look
like you are him oh i've been told that
before he's an actor right
yes he's an actor
you're you're slightly better looking
but yeah i mean you guys it's uncanny
i'm only slightly better looking oh boy
all right well i'll take it as a
compliment anyway
all right well thank you david i
appreciate it all right thank you so
much for the call
uh very very important stuff there
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping